يوم بعد يوم يتزايد الحديث عن الذكاء
الاصطناعي ومخاطره والخوف من الاعتماد
عليه بشكل كامل في الحياه اليوميه للافراد
الجديد في هذا الخصوص تحذير من الرئيس
السابق للشبكه جوجل الذي قال ان الذكاء
الاصطناعي يمكن ان يشكل خطرا على حياه
الانسان حذر من ان تكون لديه القدره على
ايذاء او قتل العديد من الاشخاص في
المستقبل القريب بسبب تطور الكبير الذي
تشهده التكنولوجيا والتشكيك في عدم القدره
على احتوائها قال ان الاشرار سيكونون
مستعدين استعمال هذه الانظمه للقيام بامور
تضر بمصالح الكثير من الناس ويبدو ان هذا
ما بدا بالفعل فمن خلال تقنيه الذكاء
الاصطناعي استطاع شخص في الصين الاحتيال
على رجل الاعمال وسرقه نحو 600 الف دولار
منه حيث قام الشاب بتغيير شكله وصوته
وجعله مشابها لصديق رجل اعمال غني وقام
باجراء مكالمه فيديو معه وطلب منه مبلغا
ماليا من اجل العمل وبالفعل ق ام صديقه
رجل الاعمال بتحويل المبلغ المطلوب الى
الشاب ومن بعدها قام بارسال رساله لصديقه
ليخبره انه تم تحويل المبلغ وعندما تفاجا
برده فعله ادرك انه تعرض لعمليه احتيال
قام بابلاغ السلطات وتمكن من استعاده جزء
من المبلغ ولم يتم التعرف الى الان على
هويه الشاب الذي استغل تقنيه الذكاء
الاصطناعي من اجل السرقه
على كل ينضم الينا عبر زوم من دبي انس
المرعي المختص في الشؤون المعلوماتيه
والتقنيه اهلا وسهلا بك معنا في العربيه
وفي تفاعلكم الذكاء الاصطناعي يتطور بشكل
كبير وبوتيره سريعه جدا بحسب الخبراء
لدرجه انه وصل الى حد تقليد صوت البشر
والتحدث بالنيابه عنه ما مدى خطوره هذه
التقنيه
مساء الخير الك سهام ولجميع المشاهدين
بالفعل او الفيديو المزيف
كان
الخبراء يتحدث عنه قبل الاشهر وقبل سنوات
بانه راح يكون خطر على البشر وعلى حياتنا
وبالفعل هذا الشيء صعب ما بدنا نخوف الناس
بقدر ما نواعيهم اكثر بانه هذا الشيء
موجود جميع قنوات الاتصال في الدنيا تتعرض
الاستغلال من قبل
المخربين والناس اللي بيستخدموها بطريقه
اجراميه خلينا نقول
واجبنا نحن انه نتجنب هذا الشيء نكون
واعيين اكثر نوعي الاطفال نوعي الشباب
الصغار نوعي الكبار بالسن من هذا الخطا
كيف تتم هاي التكنولوجيا للاسف سهام اليوم
التكنولوجيا اصبحت متوفره بعيد الجميع
بمبلغ اقل من
انا ما بدي ناقش انه هل سيصبح اذكى من
البشر لكن
اذكر نفس الموضوع كان
يعني حديث الناس لما
ظهر الانترنت كان عم يقول هذا الانترنت
راح يخرب الدنيا راح
يزيد الجرائم وبالفعل لكن لو نظرنا وقارنا
بين الاشياء الايجابيه اللي جاب لنا اياها
الانترنت مقارنه بالاشياء السلبيه لوجدنا
انه ممكن الايجابي يفوق بالكثير انا يعني
تحدثنا على شاشتكم بانه موضوع الاخلاقيات
للذكاء الاصطناعي تحدثنا كثير عنه اليوم
في مؤتمرات في العالم عم تحكي عن هذا
الموضوع اليوم صار فيه دول
تقنن الذكاء الصناعي عم بيصير قانون
للذكاء الصناعي عم بصير في تجريم
للاستخدامات غير
او للاستخدامات السلبيه والاستخدامات
الاجراميه
الذكاء الاصطناعي ليس يعني مثل مثل اي
تكنولوجيا فينا نستخدمها
بشكل سيء جدا وبشكل ايجابي
يتطلب الواعي الكبير بيتطلب القانون
بيتطلب
اليوم المشكله ليست في خطوره الذكاء
الاصطناعي فقط وعدم القدره على احتوائه
ولكن ان يتم استغلال الذكاء الاصطناعي
لاغراض خبيثه من قبل شخص اشخاص يعني سيئين
او اشخاص قد يستخدمون ذكاء الاصطناعي
لاهداف غير سليمه ما مدى خطوره ذلك بالف
خطير جدا يعني بذكرني الموضوع بنفس قصه
فيسبوك لايف وكل اللايفات اللي على جميع
منصات التواصل اليوم صار في تقريبا تاخير
لمده بعض ثواني بين انه يظهر الفيديو يعني
بين الفيديو الواقع وبين الفيديو المبث
على الشبكات ليش هذا الكلام صار من بعد
الجريمه اللي حصلت فيه نيوزلندا قبل عامين
نعول على التكنولوجيا وعلى اصحاب
تكنولوجيا الذكاء الصناعي بانهم يصنعوا
لنا مثل هاي يعني
خلينا نقول البوابات حتى يتاكدوا من انه
انا شخص عم بتحدث بشيء ايجابي او ما في اي
استغلال للاخرين ولا في اي عمليات قد تكون
مضره باي شخص ممكن عم يتلقى هذا الاتصال
او هذا الفيديو طيب انا
حدود اتصور الكبير الذي تشهده التكنولوجيا
وهل يمكن ان نصل الى وقت يعني يصير
الاعتماد على هذه التكنولوجيا
بشير كامل في حياتنا اليوميه
شوفي سهام بصراحه هو غير محدود يعني انا
اليوم انا عم حدثك الان في هذه الاثناء
بدي اصور نفسي واخلي الافاتار يصير يتحدث
عنه في كثير من المواقف لحتى يوفر عليه
وقت ويوفر ويكون انا متوفر اكثر من 24
ساعه خلال اليوم هاي البدايه على فكره
يعني اذا لو تسالينا عن النسبه بقلك
البدايه هي واحد بالميه فقط اليوم لسه نحن
يا دوب وصلنا 1% لسه امامنا الكثير من
التطور رح نشوف ونسمع اشياء ما كنا
نتوقعها
مثل ما حكيت لك صناع هاي التكنولوجيا
والقوانين ووعينا ثلاث اشياء ممكن تقلل من
مخاطر الديب فيك والذكاء الاصطناعي خصوصا
في موضوع الفيديو والحادثه الاخيره التي
سمعناها في الصين وان شاء الله بس تكون
انت الان تحكي لنا هلا يا انس من دبي انس
المرعي المختص في الشؤون المعلوماتيه
والتقنيه شكرا جزيلا
نبقى في المجال التكنولوجي فعلى الرغم من
التحذير من التطور التكنولوجي لكن لا
نستطيع اقفال اهميه التكنولوجيا في حياتنا
خصوصا في المجالين العلمي والطبي فبعد 12
عاما من الياس وعدم قدرته على المشي
استطاع رجل هولندي المشي مجددا بعد ان طور
باحثون جهاز الجسر الرقمي هذا الجهاز
عباره عن جهاز يكتشف النشاط العصبي عند
محاوله تحريك العضلات يتم تثبيته على
الدماغ ويقوم بقراءه خوارزميه معينه من
الدماغ ويحولها الى نبضات في العمود
الفقري ويقوم بتنشيط الاعصاب وتشغيل
العضلات لانتاج الحركه المقصوده صحيح ان
الجهاز لا ينتج حركه سريعه الا انه يسمح
بحركات شبه طبيعيه يتم التحكم فيها من
خلال التفكير